reputation is the best thing that you
can have if you have given enough to
people you will already have earned
their trust so that you don't need to
sell they will just say I want to work
with you and you just accept it and you
say sure the give give first until they
ask is the long-term strategy that
compounds unto itself because your
business will compound as a result of
the Goodwill that compounds in the
marketplace whereas if you have a sales
driven Org the only way that that
business compounds is if the sales guys
compounding their recruiting on your
behalf rather than because if they have
a great product they have a great sales
system